this popular protest site in the heart
of new delhi
has been hosting a unique demonstration
for the last three weeks
a mock parliament hosted by farmers
steps away
from india's real parliament security
has been increased
and only 200 people have been allowed to
take part
it's the last day and women are holding
court
the women they asserted themselves they
said
earlier we used to know how to run house
how to run kitchen
but now we know how to run parliament
how
now we know how to run our own country
so i guess for
masses that's the confidence they are
getting by this
more than half of india's population
works in agriculture
the government of prime minister
narendra modi says the three laws it
passed last year
will increase farmers income and make
the supply chain more efficient
it is indian government's duty to bring
happiness in the lives of farmers
and double their income farmers should
get good quality seeds
fertilizer better irrigation facilities
technology
and move towards growing expensive crops
they should be able to start processing
and exporting their produce
farmers should start earning more which
is the only motive of the indian
government
despite these assurances farmers who've
been camping out since november are
refusing to back down
the modi government has had 11 rounds of
talks with farmers unions and
recently appealed to them to return to
the negotiating table
but the thousands of farmers who've been
protesting here
in the outskirts of new delhi for eight
months now
say the three farm laws endanger their
livelihood
and want them repealed many of the
farmers have traveled hundreds of
kilometers
and plan to stay put until their demands
are met
i will keep coming here till the time i
am alive we have built permanent
structures here
set up tents and there is a regular
supply of water and electricity
farmers are united we're here to support
them and we will not stop protesting
until we achieve our goal
[Music]
with no signs of a resolution farmers
unions are planning another mass protest
across the country to coincide with
independence day
on august 15th pavli mithal al jazeera
new delhi